se mantiene firme en su investigación y
cualquier movimiento de los republicanos
para defender al expresidente te verá
por lo menos ser acordado Y es que la
oficina del fiscal de distrito de
Manhattan rechazó una citación de tres
presidentes de comités republicanos para
ofrecer detalles confidenciales de la
investigación contra Trump su carta con
fecha del 20 de marzo del 2023 en
contraste es una consulta sin
precedentes en un procedimiento judicial
en marcha a nivel local la carta sólo
llegó luego de que Donald Trump creara
una falsa expectativa de que podría ser
arrestado al día siguiente y sus
abogados les surgieran intervenir ningún
hecho es una base legítima para la
investigación del Congreso la
solicitudes de la carta son una
incursión ilegal en la soberanía de
Nueva York la jurisdicción de
investigación del Congreso se deriva y
está limitada por su poder para legislar
sobre asuntos federales la carta rechaza
una investigación del partido
republicano iniciada días después de que
Trump le dijera su propio arresto debido
a una investigación en su contra por el
pago de 130 mil dólares a una actriz del
cine para adultos realizado antes de su
triunfo electoral en el año 2016 un pago
que podría traducirse en falsificación
de registros comerciales fraude fiscal o
violación a la ley de financiamiento de
campañas Trump reaccionó en contra del
fiscal brack con duros mensajes en su
red social porque Brad no abandona este
caso todos dicen que no hay delito no
hice nada mal todo fue compuesto por un
loco condenado con cero credibilidad que
ha sido cuestionado por profesionales
respetados en todo momento brack se
niega a parar a pesar de la abrumadora
evidencia él es un animal apoyado por
soros que simplemente no le importa el
bien o el mal no importa cuántas
personas sean heridas Esto no es un
sistema legal esto es la gestapo esto es
Rusia y China pero peor vergüenza por
este caso se espera que el gran Jurado
retome actividades el próximo lunes
mientras los opositores al expresidente
manifestaron este jueves en las afueras
de la oficina del fiscal sin embargo
este no es el único Torbellino que
afronta el aspirante a la contienda
electoral en 2024 ya que es posible una
investigación en el estado de Georgia
por los esfuerzos de Trump para una
subversión electoral